I just want to clarify for our audience. Why? Why? I think we can just leave that where it is. When Connor says he's not in the closet right now, he's referring to the closet that he records in. Bryce, you're not actually helping? I mean... Yeah. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 30, recorded on June 5th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue our interview with Chandler Carruth and Patricia Oss, which we started in episode 29.
我想向我们的听众澄清一下。为什么？为什么？我想我们可以把它放在一边。当康纳说他现在不在衣橱里时，他指的是他录音用的那个衣橱。布莱斯，你其实帮不上忙？我是说……好吧。欢迎收看第 30 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2021 年 6 月 5 日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人是布莱斯，我们将继续我们在第 29 期中开始的对钱德勒·卡鲁斯和帕特里夏·奥斯的采访。
Chandler finishes telling us about his path to Google, and then we dive into topics including interviewing, leadership, and so much more. If you haven't listened to episode 29 already, I highly recommend you pause this, listen to episode 29 first, and come back. And then I get the two other job interviews that I've ever really had. And it was Wednesday I interviewed at google and thursday interviewed at uh apple and i failed both interviews um wait what also what was the second one the first one was the uh you didn't get your own job oh oh the second one was uh i interviewed for uh a startup in uh uh out that was spun out of the university uh that i did internships with i interviewed with them um but it wasn't much of an interview because i'd actually done an internship with them
钱德勒讲完了他加入谷歌的历程，然后我们深入探讨了面试、领导力等诸多话题。如果你还没有听过第 29 期，我强烈建议你暂停一下，先听第 29 期，然后再回来。然后我得到了我真正经历过的另外两次工作面试。星期三我在谷歌面试，星期四在苹果面试，两场面试我都搞砸了，嗯，等等，还有第二场是什么？第一场是……你没有得到你自己的工作，哦，哦，第二场是……我面试了……一个从大学孵化出来的初创公司，我在那儿实习过，我跟他们面试过，但其实不算什么面试，因为我实际上在那儿实习过。
and and so like they actually they actually were going to offer to hire me um um but i didn't really want to work in north carolina for the rest of my life and so i i wasn't super motivated to to take that particular offer okay so wait a second. So you interviewed at Google and Apple, and you were rejected by both? I wasn't rejected. I just bombed the interviews. Oh. You know what? You are like, I don't know, you're like dipped in luck or something.
所以他们其实……他们其实打算录用我，但我其实不想在北卡罗来纳州度过余生，所以我对接受那个特定的工作并不是特别积极。好吧，等等。所以你在谷歌和苹果都面试了，而且都被拒绝了？我没有被拒绝。我只是把面试搞砸了。哦。你知道吗？你就像是……我不知道，你就像是泡在福尔马林里一样走运，或者别的什么。
I don't know what happened to your life. Well, it's funny because both Chandler and I got our like first tech job through somebody, through DMing somebody on IRC. Yeah. I couldn't have been more lucky. So I do my interviews and the interviews are interesting here. So in the Google interviews, I got a really good interview that I didn't do very well on, but I also didn't crater. And it was actually a very good interview question. I ask it myself now, so I'm not going to go into that one too much. But it actually made me think about kind of challenging technical problems and explain concepts in a useful way. It thus thereby demonstrated how little professional software development experience I had. Zero. So, but it also demonstrated that I could think critically and such. That was probably my
我不知道你的人生经历了什么。嗯，有趣的是，钱德勒和我都是通过某个人，通过在 IRC 上私信某人，得到了我们的第一份科技工作。是的。我不可能更幸运了。所以我去面试了，这里的面试很有趣。所以在谷歌的面试中，我有一场面试表现得很好，虽然我没有做得很好，但也没有搞砸。而且这其实是一个非常好的面试问题。我现在自己也会问这个问题，所以我不会过多展开。但它确实让我思考了某种具有挑战性的技术问题，并以一种有用的方式解释了概念。它从而展示了我当时有多少专业的软件开发经验。零。所以，但它也证明了我可以进行批判性思考之类的。这可能是我
strongest performance. There was another one that was a terrible interview question that was basically a brain teaser about how floating point works. And I did really well on that one because I happened to have struggled with floating point because I happened to have worked on LLVM. But like, it's a terrible interview question that like it didn't, it shouldn't have been a significant factor. The other interview question that I remember that I've talked about publicly as just like one of my least favorite interview questions was like, it was the last interview of the day at google um and i you have to understand like this interview process was horrible for me so i had one outfit that was like interview level professional uh because i was a graduate student paying for things from credit cards right and uh that outfit of course wasn't what i was going to
表现最好的一次。还有另一个面试问题是一个糟糕的面试问题，基本上是一个关于浮点数如何工作的脑筋急转弯。我在那道题上做得很好，因为我碰巧一直在跟浮点数作斗争，因为我碰巧在 LLVM 上工作过。但是，这是一个糟糕的面试问题，它不应该成为一个重要的因素。我记得的另一个面试问题，我曾在公开场合谈论过，认为它是我最不喜欢的面试问题之一，就像是……那是谷歌当天的最后一场面试，你需要明白，这个面试过程对我来说太糟糕了。所以我只有一套可以说是面试级别的专业服装，因为我是一个靠信用卡付账单的研究生，对吧？然后，那套服装当然不是我打算在苹果面试时穿的，因为在苹果，面试时的穿着很重要。所以，对于我的谷歌面试，我穿着牛仔帽和毕业论文连帽衫就去了。现在他们不就期望这样吗？什么是毕业论文连帽衫？就像我一直穿着而且没机会洗的
wear at apple because at apple it matters what you look like when you interview at Apple. And so, for my Google interview, I showed up in jeans and my thesis hoodie. Isn't that like what they expect now? What is a thesis hoodie? Like the hoodie I'd been wearing and hadn't had a chance to launder
毕业论文的那个学院的连帽衫。我是这么想的。听到毕业论文，我还以为你是指你拿到了一个，你知道的，我通过了论文答辩。不，不，不，不。我误解了。不，不，不。就像我周一刚通过了毕业论文答辩，整个人有点晕晕乎乎的，周二打印出来提交了，然后坐上飞机，飞越大洋，飞越大洋睡了一晚，然后早上 9 点到达谷歌的校园，我坐在大厅里，周围都是穿着西装、拿着公文包、看起来精明强干准备面试的人，而我穿着牛仔裤和毕业论文连帽衫，这感觉真是别有一番风味。所以最后一位面试官出现了，他要求……他一出现就说，我想要你在白板上实现 wget，就像那个工具一样，直接实现它，开始吧。我看着就像是
the college of the thesis. That's what I thought. By thesis, I thought you meant you got like a, you know, I defended my thesis. No, no, no, no. I misunderstood. No, no, no. It's like I'm sitting kind of
我当时想，我这辈子从来没做过网络编程，我真的连 socket open paren 都没有写过一次，我没有……只是它从来没出现过，这不是我在学校里特别关注的焦点。我写的所有代码都围绕着编译器和视频游戏图形，而不是围绕着网络。他看着我，就像是，呃，好吧，但是……好吧，好吧，只要跟我过一遍你将如何实现 wget，你可以用伪代码，这没问题，我不在乎你是否懂任何网络知识……但跟我过一遍你需要实现 wget 的步骤，你知道的，发送一个 http 请求并获得响应。我看着他，就像我一无所知
kind of punch drunk from having defended a thesis on Monday, printed it, submitted it on Tuesday, got on a plane, flown across the country, slept after flying across the country for one night got up and like arrived at google's campus at 9 a.m and i'm sitting in a lobby surrounded by people in suits with portfolios like looking sharp like for an interview in my jeans and my thesis like hoodie it was it was something else so the last interviewer shows up and he asks and he like shows up he's like i want you to implement wget like the tool just implement it on the whiteboard go go i looked at just like
关于……就像 http，我不知道这个协议，我不知道这里需要什么，我不知道我需要……他眨着眼看着我，然后说，你知道你在哪里面试吧？是的，这就是我当时的想法，这可是谷歌，然后我说，是的，但我一直在研究编译器和编程语言，我的简历上就是这么写的，你不应该对此感到惊讶，我其实并没有在简历上声称其他任何东西。所以他有点……所以他就像是，好吧，把你懂的画成图表。我基本上就说，你会向服务器发送一个请求，服务器会发送一个响应。然后他说，我们来谈谈你最喜欢的编程语言。顺便说一句，各位，这是面试结束的代号，我要把剩下的 45 分钟填满。
it's like i was like i've i've never done networking network programming in my life like i literally have not written socket open paren once i didn't like just it just never came up it was not a particular focus of mine in school i just like all the code i'd written i was all around compilers and video game graphics and not around like networking and he looks at me it's like i mean oh okay but like fine fine just walk me through how this like like like you can use pseudocode that's fine i don't care if you know any network like but like walk me through like what you would need to implement wget like you know send an http request and get a response and i looked him like like i do not know anything about
噢，天哪。是的，我的面试进展得并不顺利，你会录用你吗？可能不会。老实说，这是一个好问题，可能不会。所以我可以告诉你为什么我被录用了，是因为我的开源工作。
the like http i don't know the protocol i have no idea what's needed here i don't know how i need who blinks at me and he's like you do know where you're interviewing right yeah i was that was that was basically what i was thinking it's like this is google and and i was like yes but i've worked on like compilers and programming languages it says so on my resume like you shouldn't be surprised by this i didn't actually like claim anything else on my resume um and and so he kind of like like, and so, like, he's like, okay, well, diagram what you know. And I basically, like, said, like, well, you're going to send a request to the server, and the server's going to send a response. And he's like, let's talk about your favorite programming language. By the way, folks, that's code for the interview's over, and I'm going to fill the remaining 45 minutes.
我正要说的是，我几乎可以肯定，他们录用钱德勒的原因，以及他们特意为他安排面试的原因，与他在面试中的表现毫无关系。就像我以前可能讲过这个故事一样。如果没有，我提前向我即将尴尬的团队成员道歉，但我不会说出名字。但是几年前在 CPPCon 上有人接近我，说，嘿，我想来你们团队工作。我告诉她，把你的简历发给我。她照做了。这不是我以前认识的人。
Oh, dear. Yeah, my interview didn't go well would you have hired you? probably not good question honestly probably not so I can tell you why I got hired it was because of my open source work
我们是那年在会议上认识的。我聊了一会儿，觉得她很impressive（令人印象深刻）。她把简历发给了我，我看了她的简历和 GitHub 大约五分钟。然后我想，是的，我现在已经有了我需要的所有信息。面试还是会有的。但是……我在这里当场决定，在看了这个人的简历五分钟后，我要录用这个人。
I was about to say that I'm almost certain that the reason that they hired Chandler and the reason that they went out of their way to set up an interview with him had nothing to do with how he did an interview. Like I think I may have told this story in the past. And if not, I apologize in advance to my team member who I'm about to embarrass, but not by name. But I had somebody who approached me at CPPCon a few years ago and said, hey, I think I want to come work at your team. And I told her, send me your resume. And she did. And this isn't somebody that I'd known previously.
我们确实录用了，而且结果非常棒。而且，你知道，有时候你就是知道这个人有，你知道的，丰富的开源背景。你就是想要这样的人。所以，因为那个最初让我把简历发过去的人知道我在 LLPM 上的工作，而且他知道谷歌的招聘流程是如何运作的。所以他确保除了我的面试之外，他们也了解我的开源工作。据我了解，这仍然不是特别令人印象深刻。我看了我当时做的开源工作，确实不是特别印象深刻。
We'd met at the conference that year. I talked a little bit, thought she was impressive. She sent me her resume and I looked at her resume and her GitHub for about five minutes. And I was like, yeah, I have all the information that I need now. And there will be interviews that will happen. But like, I am deciding here at this spot, five minutes after looking at this person's resume, that I am going to hire this person.
也许在那个时代它令人印象深刻。不。不，不过这是关于潜力的，你知道的，我……我认为这是我的技能之一，能够识别出未被发掘的潜力之类的。有时候，重要的不是这个人做过什么，而是你从他们做过的事情中看到了什么潜力。也许某人并没有做太多事情，但如果他们处于职业生涯的极早期，而当时的钱德勒就处在职业生涯的极早期，所以你知道的，说实话，我猜是因为这是你从 IRC 上认识的人，钱德勒，对吧？
And we did hire and it worked out wonderfully. And, you know, for sometimes you just know it's somebody that has, you know, a prolific open source background. And it's just like, you want that person. And so because the person who got me to send the resume in in the first place knew about my work in LLPM and he knew how the hiring process at Google worked. And so he made sure that in addition to my interviews, they also were aware of the open source work. And my understanding is that this was still not especially impressive. And I've looked at my open source work from then, and it was not especially impressive.
它不是一个从 IRC 新认识的人吗？它是那种你以前只在 IRC 上互动过的人吗？我从来没有见过他们。但比起你做出的开源贡献，这可能更少关乎这些，而更多关乎你如何与那个人互动。也就是你在那个 IRC 频道上问过的问题类型。好吧，好吧，好吧，那样的讨论。那我有个问题，因为你有……康纳，你在这件事上可以退出的……但是布莱斯和钱德勒都在现实生活中见过我。你们在各种媒体上与我有过互动。也许还看过我演讲。
Maybe it was impressive for its time. No. No, it's about potential, though though you know like i i i think this is like one of my skill sets is like being able to like like recognize untapped potential or whatnot like sometimes it's not about what the person's done but it's about what potential you see and what they've done like maybe maybe somebody hasn't done a lot but if they're if they're like very early stage career and at this point in theler's life he would have been very early stage and so you you know and honestly my guess is because this was somebody that you knew chandler from irc right
那么，我不知道你们有没有看过我的 GitHub，这是否足以让你们说，我想也许我们应该录用她？是的。这在很多方面都行不通，因为你的职业生涯不是超级新，才刚刚开始。不。对吧？所以还有一堆其他的问题我想了解。
that it was not somebody that was like new from irc is it somebody that you'd interacted with previously only on irc i've never met them but but it was probably less about the open source contributions that you made and was probably more about how you'd interacted with that person so the sort of questions you'd asked on that irc channel okay okay okay sort of discussion then i have a question because you have like connor you you can you can bow out on this one but but both bryce and ch Chandler have met me in real life. You've interacted with me on various media. And maybe watched me speak.
这就让我们进入了那个列表。这也确实让我们过渡到了那个话题。所以我会帮你们了解一下这个列表。所以这个列表基本上分为你职业生涯的四个阶段。它很大程度上围绕着处理冲突。所以初级阶段，我给它们命名了，所以你们可能不同意对它们的命名。但初级角色很大程度上是关于团队内部的冲突。所以与其他团队成员，但在很大程度上是同等水平的。
So would that be, I don't know if you have looked at my GitHub, but would that be sufficient for you to say, I think maybe we should hire her? Yeah. This doesn't compute in a bunch of ways because you're not like super new in your career and just starting out. No. Right? And so there are a whole bunch of other questions that I would want to know about.
以及团队内部在项目上的失败，但这是非常直接针对个人的事情。现在我在解读，所以你可以告诉我我是不是……是的。第二阶段我称之为高级。这更多的是关于建立共识，以及看得比团队更远，看向客户和其他团队。然后，同样，这里也要处理冲突。然后是我觉得很难的一个，也就是某种中层角色，现在它关乎愿景、协调团队，并且具有更广泛的
And that brings us to the list. And that does segue us over. So I will catch you us to the list. And that does segue us over. So I will catch you up on the list. So the list is basically four stages of your career. And it's a lot around handling conflict. So the junior, I have named them, so you might not agree with the naming of them. But the junior role is a lot about conflicts within the team. So with other team members, but very much at a peer level.
多团队性质，但仍然非常亲力亲为，在我看来……然后，你知道，你处于更多的是领导力那种角色，技术领导力那种角色，也就是第四个阶段。现在你处于影响更高层的地方，比如 XX，还要着眼于战略，不仅在公司内部，还在整个行业内。而且同样是处理……但我不……这里有一点冲突，但看起来与其说是处理冲突，不如说是如何推动事情发展。是的，这大致能描述这些吗？我想我唯一想调整的是这里的层级，我觉得第三组是……
And failures within the team with the project, but something that is very directly to the person. Now I'm interpreting, so you can tell me if I'm... Yeah. The second one I call senior. And that's more about like building consensus as well as looking further than the team, looking towards the customer and towards other teams. And then also, again, dealing with conflict here. And then the one that I had a hard time, so like middle something role, and that's now in vision and and and aligning teams and having more of a broad
所以我觉得这是对的，比如初级或入门级，比如工程。然后第二个是，你知道的，高级或某种团队主管，比如项目主管之类的。第三个，我认为已经真正进入了领导力阶段。这就是为什么……这就是为什么第二层和第三层之间会有很大的转变。第四个不是关于进入领导力角色，而是扩展你的领导力，对吧？所以有点像是领导力的放大方面，当你想要在一个更广阔的范围和规模上运作时。所以很多人思考或好奇的一件事，就是你如何从一个阶段过渡到下一个阶段。那么你认为自己今天在这四个阶段中处于什么位置？
multi-team kind of thing but but still pretty hands-on you know it seems to me um and then you know you're in the more of the leadership kind of role tech leadership kind of role uh which is like the fourth one and now you're in influencing higher uh like like the like the xx and and and also looking at at strategy but not only within the company itself but also in the industry and again dealing with with but but i i don't there are a little bit of a conflict there but there it seems not so much dealing with conflict and more like how to to move things yeah would that roughly describe these i think the only thing i want to tweak about that is the the leveling here i'm really the third group is so I
哦，天哪，我不知道。还有一件事值得一提吗？我不确定。我们可以忽略这个。我甚至可以把它剪掉。但在大多数公司里，也有两条不同的轨道，我认为。有管理轨道和 IC 轨道。IC 代表个人贡献者。
think of this as right, like, junior or like entry level, right, like, like engineering, right. And then the second one is as you know, senior or kind of like, team lead, right, like, like, you know, project lead, that kind of thing. The third one, I think is already really into leadership. And that's, that's why that's why it shifts a lot between the second and the third level here. And the fourth one is not about kind of entering a leadership role, but scaling your leadership, right? And so kind of the scaled up aspects of leadership, when you want to kind of operate at an even broader scope and scale. So one of the things that a lot of people think about or wonder is how you transition from one one stage to the next. And so where do you consider yourself to be in these four stages today?
这在这里值得一提吗？我认为是的。但我认为这里还有一个常见的误解，那就是几乎总是存在第三条轨道。有些公司将管理和领导力结合在一起，但并非总是如此。所以我认为你应该把单纯的个人贡献者、领导力和管理分开来考虑？我的意思是，我们可以想象很多东西。我无法代表其他公司发言。我只……就像你刚才听到了我是如何在谷歌找到工作的。那是我的第一份真正的工作，所以我真的无法谈论谷歌以外的任何事情。但在谷歌，至少有两条
Oh, gosh, I don't know. Is it also worth mentioning? I'm not sure. We can ignore this. I can cut it out even. But at most companies, too, there is two different tracks that I think. There's the management track and the IC track. IC standing for individual contributor.
轨道，对吧？你要么走技术轨道，要么走管理轨道。它们都会上升，你可以在任何一条轨道上成为领导者。所以它们都有这里的成长潜力。但它们确实改变了你的重点。而且它们之间也有很多重叠，它们不是被死板隔开的轨道，它们真正关乎的是你的主要重点是什么，在你的工作和职业生涯中。好吧，所以你走的是技术轨道，我猜是的。我碰巧在谷歌走的是技术轨道，我不知道，我的意思是，我……我很难……我不知道，我不想这样，康纳你可能得把这个剪掉，我不知道该怎么说我在哪里。一方面，我觉得我对所有这些东西一无所知。
Is that worth mentioning here? I think it is. But I think there's also a common misperception here, which is that there's almost always a third track. Some companies, the management and leadership are combined, but that's not always the case. So I think that you should think separately about solely an individual contributor, leadership, and management? I mean, we can imagine a bunch of stuff. I can't speak to any other companies. I've only, like, you've heard the story now of how I got my job at Google. That was the first real job I got, so I can't really speak to anything outside of Google. But at Google, at least, there are two
另一方面，在谷歌的这个阶段，我相当坚定地在……你知道的，在这个第四个桶里运作。我很幸运能进入谷歌。但后果之一就是，以谷歌底层员工的身份进入，而且勉强通过面试，这在某种程度上震撼了我的世界。我突然变得有些奇怪地雄心勃勃。就像在职业生涯上有雄心，还是像什么？
tracks, right? You're either on kind of the technical track or the management track. And they both go up, and you can become a leader on either track. And so they both have the kind of growth potential here. But they do change your focus. And there's plenty of overlap between them too they're not they're not like rigidly separated tracks they're really about you know what your primary focus is as like in your job and in your career okay so you are on a technical track i assume so i haven't been to be on the technical track on uh at google and i i don't know i mean i i i struggle to be kind of i don't of, I don't want to be, Connor, you might have to cut this out, I don't know how to say where I am. Like, on one hand, I think I don't have a clue about any of this stuff.
是的。哦，好吧。但你说你在谷歌走的是技术轨道，钱德勒，但你确实有直接下属，对吧？哦，是的。所以我在谷歌走的是技术轨道，但我实际上在这一点上管理着一个大型组织。就像我的组织里有 60 多个人，我不仅负责
On the other hand, at this point at Google, I'm pretty solidly in, you know, operating in the fourth bucket here. I've been very, I was very lucky to get into Google. But one of the consequences is that kind of coming in at Google as like the bottom end and just barely getting past the interviews kind of shook my world a bit. And I got kind of weirdly ambitious all of a sudden. Like ambitious like career- wise or ambitious like?
管理人，还要管理经理。对，你看，这有点……我认为这真的因公司而异。就像我处于一个……你知道的，领导角色。我……我的意思是，这些天我在英伟达花很少的时间写代码，但我没有直接下属。这只是那种……我有机会进入一个有直接下属的轨道，但我认为这不会让我上升得那么高。在英伟达，有一个角色，你可以成为人的领导，而无需……实际上管理任何人。所以我认为这真的因公司而异。那那个角色叫什么？比如，那是首席工程师还是什么？
Yes. Oh, okay. But you say you're on the technical track at Google Chandler, but you do have direct reports, right? Oh yeah. So I'm on the technical track at Google, but I actually manage a large organization at this point. It's like I have over 60 people in my organization and I'm responsible for not just
所以在英伟达，这个词通常与架构师联系在一起。但英伟达也不是一家层级非常死板的公司。所以头衔在英伟达并不是那么重要。你可以塑造自己的角色。所以真正的原因是，在某个时候我决定，让我完成更多事情的方法是减少作为个人贡献者的时间，花更多的时间作为人的领导者。但无论如何，虽然我有下属，但这并不是普遍现象，甚至对于技术阶梯上的人来说也不是那么常见。而且随着时间的推移，我可能会有更少的下属，而不是更多。但这有点像……你知道的，它来来去去。
managing people, but managing managers. Yeah. See, and it's a bit, I think it really depends from like company to company. Like I'm in a, you know, a leadership role. I don't, I mean, I spend very little of my time these days at NVIDIA writing code, but I don't have direct reports. And that's just sort of the, I had i had opportunities to go into a a track where i would have direct reports but it i did not think that that would allow me to rise as high um and in nvidia there's you know there's a role where you can be a leader of people without you know being without actually managing any people so i think it really depends from company to company. So what is that role called? Like, is that like a principal engineer or what is this?
我所在的团队非常需要有人挺身而出，做更高水平的组织管理。所以我承担了这个角色，因为有这种需求。但在某些情况下，我的目标很大程度上也是……你知道的，随着时间的推移，在那个角色上取代我自己。我希望更多地回归……我在管理和组织领导力方面已经达到了我想要的极限。我希望未来钟摆能稍微摆回技术方面。是的，只是，我认为值得一提的是，对于那些没有……正在听这个的、不在我所说的技术优先公司（如英伟达或谷歌）的人来说，或者，你知道的，有很多大名字，但也有很多较小的
So at NVIDIA, usually that term is associated with like architect. But also NVIDIA is not a company that has a very rigid hierarchy. So titles aren't really that significant at NVIDIA. You get to shape your own role. So it was really just that at some point I decided that the way for me to get more things done was to spend less of my time as an individual contributor, more of my time sort of as a leader of people. But for what it's worth, while I have reports that's not universal, it's not even all that common for people on the technical ladder. And I'm probably going to be having fewer reports over time, not more. But this is kind of like, you know, it's come and gone.
名字也是技术优先的。我最初在一家不是技术优先的金融公司工作。吸引我想要转向技术优先公司的最大吸引力之一，就是他们有这种轨道划分。在许多非技术优先公司，只有一条轨道，在最初的几个级别，你是技术的。但如果你想超越这个级别，你必须转入管理层。而我，至少在我职业生涯的这个阶段，真的不想管理人们。我想解决困难的技术问题。而在技术优先公司的 IC 轨道上，如果你愿意的话，通常你不需要有下属。你可以从高级工程师晋升为首席工程师，通过解决更困难的技术问题、指导……
The group I was in had a real need for someone to kind of step up and do kind of higher level organizational management. And so I stepped into the role because there was a need for that. But in some ways, my goal has also been to largely kind of, you know, replace myself in that role over time. I'm hopeful to go back even more towards, I'm about as far towards the kind of management and organizational leadership as I ever want to get. I'm hoping the pendulum swings back a little bit more towards technical things in the future. Yeah, just, I think it's worth mentioning because for those that aren't, that are listening to this, that aren't at what I would call a technology first company like NVIDIA or Google or, you know, there's a lot of large names, but there's also a lot of smaller
年轻的高级工程师等，产生巨大的影响力。这是基本上每家技术优先公司都存在的路径，对于像我这样想要遵循这条路径的人来说，至少在我的职业生涯的这个阶段，这太棒了，有很多公司，当你达到这种水平时，然后他们会说，好吧，如果你想进步，你必须开始管理人们。有很多人……我不想代表所有人，但至少对我自己而言，我非常清楚，也许……也许在某个时候我可能想管理员工，但绝对现在我只是……我太喜欢敲代码了。
names that are the technology first. I first worked at a financial company that was not technology first. And one of the big draws to wanting to switch to a technology first company is the fact that they have this delineation between tracks. And at a lot of non-technology first companies, there's a single track where for the first few levels, you're technical. But if you want to progress past that level, you have to switch to management. And I, at least at this point in my career, don't really want to be managing people. I want to be solving hard technical problems. And at Technology First companies on the IC track, typically you don't have to have reports if you want to. You can go from your senior engineer to principal engineer and have like a big impact by solving the harder technical problems by mentoring, you know,
当我在思科时，他们有……他们有首席工程师的概念，这实际上是一件……因为我们就像……我们有一个卫星办公室，思科收购了公司，所以我们有一个思科收购的公司……但是……所以我基本上自己找到了所有关于这个首席工程师的东西的文档，其中一部分是……它基本上说，要成为一名首席工程师，你必须已经做过这项工作。这是一个事实。有趣的是，我当时正在做这项工作。但是……但是后来当我被告知……当我提出我想朝那个方向发展时。他们告诉我，不，这是一个荣誉头衔。这就像我们给那些已经在这里呆了 15 年的人的头衔，然后你知道他们得到了这个头衔，因为他们的头发变白了
younger senior engineers and whatnot. And that's a path that exists at basically every single tech first company, which like for me, someone that wants to like follow that path, at least at this point in my career is like awesome where there's a lot of companies that you hit this sort of like level and then they're like, well, if you want to progress, you got to start managing people. And there's a lot of, I don't want to speak for everyone, but like, at least for myself, I definitely know maybe, maybe at some point I might want to manage folks, but definitely right now I just, I love typing code too much.
或者别的什么。这很不幸。是的，是的，我认为任何时候你看到一家公司在……资历和级别之间有很强的联系，这通常是一个有点危险的信号。我的意思是，很明显，我认为这……你知道的，通常在某种程度上会存在于某些公司中，但这不应该是，头衔不应该是荣誉性质的，对吧？头衔不应该留给那些呆了 15 年的人。所以……但是……我之所以想到这一点，是因为获得这个的要求之一是不能有任何直接下属，所以当我在那里的时候，他们把这个头衔给了一个人，而那个人不得不……不得不失去他们的直接下属才能获得这个头衔。有趣。
When I was at Cisco, they had, they had this idea of a principal engineer and it was actually like something that because we're like we have like a satellite office thing thing cisco buys company so we had a company cisco body um so but but so i basically found like all of the documentation for this like principal engineer stuff myself and part of that was like um it said basically to become a principal engineer, you kind of had to have already been doing the work. That was like a thing. And the funny thing is that I was at that time doing the work. But but but then I was told when I was like I brought it up that I want to kind of go in that direction. And they told me, no, this is an honorary title. This is like we give people that they've been here for like 15 years then you know they get this title because their hair turned gray
这对我来说很奇怪。这很奇怪。是的，特别是如果它是荣誉性质的。所以当我在……今年早些时候，我转到了英伟达的一个新角色，我有一个……有机会考虑转向管理轨道。但我没有这样做的原因，是它有点违反直觉，康纳之前在谈论某些公司为了晋升到下一层管理者，你必须管理，为了达到那层之上的层级，我将不得不
or something that's unfortunate yeah yeah i think anytime you see a company that has um uh a strong association between seniority and rank, that's usually a little bit of a red flag. I mean, it's obviously, I think it's, you know, it's usually going to be present to some degree at some company, but that should not be, titles shouldn't be honorary, right? Titles shouldn't be something that you reserve for the folks that have been there for 15 years um so but but the reason why i thought about it was because one of the one of the requirements for getting this was that you couldn't have any direct reports and so they gave the title to to uh to someone while i was there and they that that person had to to uh to lose their direct reports to be able to get the title. Interesting.
管理比我在职业生涯未来五年内愿意管理的更多的人。而在技术轨道上，我可以处于这样一个角色：我是我乐意领导的人数规模的领导者，甚至更多。而且我有很大的成长空间，在我目前的级别之上至少有两个级别，我可以在未来五年内触及，而不会超出我的舒适区。这就是为什么我决定留在技术轨道上。好的。所以你们都在谈论……你和钱德勒至少都在谈论这种领导力的概念，但与管理脱钩。所以你们在某种程度上谈论的是技术领导力，而且它似乎有……这种表达对你们来说是有内容的。那这意味着什么？我的意思是，对我来说，它是关于……你知道的，影响和设定方向。这就是为什么你可以看到这开始展现在我在这里探究的问题中。它是关于建立一个方向和战略，
It was weird to me. That's weird. Yeah, especially if it's honorary. So when I, earlier this year, I switched to sort of a new role at NVIDIA and I had the, there was an opportunity for me to like consider switching over to the management track. But the reason that I didn't was that it sort of unintuitively, Connor was talking about how at some companies you have to manage to get to the next tier of manager and the tier beyond that, I would have to be
以及你这样做时所处的范围。它所解决的问题的范围，你部署到它的影响力的范围。不过，这到底是什么意思？这听起来很含糊。给我举个例子。当然。这的一个例子将是你的……
managing more people than I thought I would be comfortable with managing in the next five years of my career. Whereas on the technical track, I could be in a role where I was a leader for the size of people that I was comfortable being a leader for, or even more. And there was plenty of room for me to grow, that there were at least two levels above where I was that I could reach for in the next five years without going outside of my comfort zone. And so that's why I decided to stay in the technical track. Okay. So you're both speaking, like both you and Chandler, at least, are talking about this idea of leadership, but separated from management. So you're talking about technological leadership in some way,
我从我自己的经验中举一个例子，对吧？如果我们在谷歌，我们实际上在用……你知道的，GCC，当时的编译器并没有真正满足谷歌的需求，对吧？实际上弄清楚、意识到我们所需要的不仅仅是一个更好的编译器，例如，是为了在编译器之上构建工具，以帮助我们的代码库扩展和我们的开发人员处理 C++ 的挑战。
and it seems to have, like, that expression seems to have content for you. So what does that mean? I mean, for me, it's about, you know, influencing and, like, setting direction. And this is why you can kind of see this showing up in the kind of questions that I was probing here. It's about establishing a direction and a strategy
很明显我们需要一个不同的平台。所以我必须要做的事情之一就是到处去说服公司的每个人，不，我们将从在 GCC 之上构建方向性地转向在 Clang 和 LLVM 之上构建。不是因为它们更好。当时它们甚至没有更好。作为编译器，它们实际上更糟。而是因为它们会给我们提供我们需要的杠杆作用。
and the scope at which you do that. The scope of the problems that are solved by it, the scope of influence you have to deploy to it. What does that mean, though? That sounds very vague. Give me an example. Sure. So an example of this would be your,
我们将能够在它们之上构建我们需要构建的工具。因此，作为一个方向，我们必须改变整个公司的方向，以便我们能够构建这些工具。所以你是怎么做到的？很大程度上，这是关于在正确的时间向正确的人提供带有良好证据的好的论点。所以你必须能够进入那个房间，我想，向那些人展示。这是第一件事。你确实需要接触到你需要说服的人。然而，至少在谷歌，这一部分实际上可能是最简单的一部分。如果你付出足够的努力，你几乎肯定可以和谷歌的任何人交谈，
I'll take one from my own experience here, right? If we're at Google and we're actually using, you know, GCC, and at the time the compiler is not really meeting Google's needs, right? Actually figuring, realizing that the needs that we have are not for just a better compiler, but for example, for tools built on top of the compiler in order to help our code base scale and our developers kind of deal with the challenges of C++.
为了尝试说服他们某事。你不太可能找不到一个你可以交谈的人，即使他们有点……你知道的，有一些你需要经历的层级，对吧？你至少可以找到第一层的人。如果你能说服他们，他们会确保你能和公司下一层的人交谈。这是一个渐进的过程，对吧？这花费了我们……这可能花了，我想说，六到七年才真正完全在谷歌确立这种方向转变，对吧？一路上有很多里程碑。在这一过程的每个阶段，都有很多……很多将这种方向性战略推得更远、更远、更远的过程。令人惊讶的是，即使是我概述的事情，由于我们拥有一套不同的用例，将编译器从一个技术栈更改为一个不同的技术栈，这本身也只是一个渐进的步骤。一切都
It became very clear that we needed a different platform. And so one of the things I had to do was to go around and convince everyone at the company that like, no, we're going to directionally pivot from building on top of GCC to building on top of Clang and LLVM. Not because they're better. At the time, they weren't even better. They were actually worse as a compiler. But because they're going to give us the leverage we need.
分解为这些渐进的组件。所以这实际上是改变我们在谷歌编写 C++ 代码的战略方向的渐进步骤。其中的另一个组成部分是谷歌在标准化过程中变得更加深入地参与，并试图推动行业和……哦，领导力意味着拥有愿景，然后激励人们相信这个愿景。所以我认为这根本上是关于人的。某人做某事，说，照我说的做，因为我告诉过你，以及因为你已经说服他们这是一件令人兴奋的事情，或者这是正确的方向，或者这是他们应该相信的事情，从而激励他们去做。我认为这才是领导力的真正意义所在。你必须了解你需要解决的问题、你所处的业务、你的用户的需求，然后你必须能够确定
We're going to be able to build the tools we need to build on top of them. And so as a direction, we have to kind of pivot the entire company's direction so that we can build those tools. So how do you do that? Largely, it's about presenting a good argument with good evidence to support it to the right people at the right time. And so you have to be able to get into that room, I guess, to those people. That is one thing. You do have to have access to the people who you need to kind of convince. However, at least at Google, that part is actually probably the easiest part. If you put in enough effort, you can almost certainly talk to anyone at Google that you
什么是该问题的解决方案。然后你需要让你的员工相信这个问题，相信你的用户，相信业务，并相信这个解决方案是正确的道路。我认为我的经历可能因花了太多时间在社区驱动的项目、标准委员会和志愿者组织上而受到了一些影响，因为当你在一个志愿者组织时，你不能只是告诉人们做什么。你必须与……你知道的，当人们做志愿者时，他们会自愿做他们想做的事，你不能只是给他们下命令。所以也许我的经历受到了一些影响，你知道的……在很多情况下，我能让人们做事的唯一方法就是我能激励他们去做，因为我不能只是命令他们去做。我想……我想让每个人都知道一个秘密。这永远是真的。所以很多人认为……
need to in order to try and convince them of something. It's very unlikely that you can't find a person that you talk to, even if they're kind of, you know, some layers that you have to work through, right? You can at least find the person at the first layer. And if you can convince them, they're going to make sure you can talk to the person at the next layer of the company. And it's an incremental process, right? This took us, this took probably, I would say, six to seven years to really establish this directional shift at Google fully, right? And there were just a lot of milestones along the way. And there was a lot of, you know, lot of pushing this directional strategy further and further and further at each stage of this. And the surprising thing is that even the thing I've outlined, changing the compiler from one technology stack to a different technology stack because of a different set of use cases that we have, that's actually itself just an incremental step. Everything kind of
开源或标准委员会或其他事情在这里是不同的。我不这么认为。我认为这实际上是千真万确的，对吧？在谷歌，我们现在是一家大公司，对吧？我们是一家大公司，所以有大量的团队和经理，我看到他们基本上收到方向，比如去构建这个东西。如果那个团队的人不相信这是一个好主意，它每次都会失败，就像……没有……当我的一群人、一个团队不相信他们在构建什么但他们构建了一个成功的东西时，我零成功案例——我字面意思是零成功案例。我有过一个例子，但我有一个例子是因为非常悲伤的原因。因为当我注意到你在谈论这个时，你从来没有真正谈论过让人们听你说话。
decomposes into these kind of incremental components. And so that's actually an incremental step of changing the direction of the strategy for how we write C++ code at Google. And another component of that was Google kind of becoming much more heavily involved in the standardization process and trying to push on the industry and the oh, the leadership means having the vision and then inspiring people to believe in that vision. So I think it's fundamentally about people. somebody to do something, saying, do this because I told you to, and inspiring them to do it because you've convinced them that this is an exciting thing or that this is the right direction to go in or that this is something that they should believe in. And I think that's really what leadership is about. You have to understand the problem that you need to be solving, the business that you're in, what your users need, and then you need to be able to identify
然而，我整个职业生涯基本上是我走进的每一个房间，我都必须证明我有能力在这个房间里，所以这就像我整个职业生涯都是从一走进门时的负 500 开始的……所以……所以我……就像我在思科内部设法做出的转变，我们为会议室构建这些网真系统，我做了大量的研究，我做了大约 20 个小时的演讲，我构建了原型，我构建了一个实际的……就像一个……一个……一个带有摄像头、麦克风阵列和触控屏的完整产品，我们上面有网页内容。而且就像……我真的必须这样做，因为没有人听我的，因为我是个女孩。所以我为了让别人听我说话付出了多大的努力。当我走进房间说，我们现在做事的方式行不通时。要让别人真正听进去，太难了。
what is the solution to that problem. And then you need to get your people to believe in the problem, to believe in your users, to believe in the business, and to believe that the solution is the right way forward. And I think that my experience may be a bit colored by working so much on community-driven projects and standards committees and volunteer organizations, because when you're in a volunteer organization, you can't just tell people what to do. You have to work with, you know, when people volunteer, they're going to volunteer to do what they want and you can't just give them orders. And so perhaps my experience is a bit colored by that, of, you know, of that, that the only way that I can get people to do things in a lot of contexts is if I can inspire them to do it because I can't just tell them to do it. I want to, I want to let everyone in on a secret. That's always true. So a lot of people think that like
当他们接受了我的想法时。他们召集了一个由 20 名男性工程师参加的会议，却没有叫我去。我想你是完全正确的。而且我认为像钱德勒和我这样的人，我觉得我们往往是声音很大的人，我们有强烈的意见，而且我们分享这些意见没有什么问题。而且我认为因为我们是……你知道的，科技界的白男，这是非常被接受的，对吧？你知道的，就像如果我把大部分时间花在开会和向人们推销没有人还相信的疯狂
open source or standards committees or other things are different here. I don't think they are. I think this is actually truly common, right? at google we're we're a big company these days right we're a big company so there are plenty of teams and managers who i've seen basically like receive direction like go build this thing over here if the people on that team don't believe believe that this is a good idea it fails every single time with like like there's no i have zero success examples when a group of people a team didn't believe in what they were building but they built a thing that was successful like i have literally zero examples i i have an example but i have an example for like really sad reasons. So because one of the things that I noticed when you are talking about this is that you are never really talking about getting people to listen to you.
想法上，并试图说服他们相信这一点。对我来说这样做更容易，因为我知道我这样做是可以接受的，而且我对此感到自信。但是你，帕特里夏，作为科技界的女性，第一，你不会觉得这样做那么舒服，因为你知道对你有巨大的偏见；第二，人们听你说话要难得多。我常常是那个做演示的人，但在会议上人们会让我闭嘴。我有一个高管在会议上说，你以为你是谁？而我说，我只是来回答你问我的问题。
Whereas, so my entire career has basically been every room I walk into, I have to prove that I am competent to be in that room so that is like my entire career is is working from like negative 500 the moment I walk through the door and and so so so I so like the shift that I I managed to do inside of Cisco we build these telepresence systems for for conferencing rooms I did a massive amount of research I did like probably like 20 hours of presentations I built prototypes I built an actual like like a like a like a full product with cameras and microphone arrays and a touchscreen, and we had web stuff on it. And it was like, I had to really, because nobody would listen to me, because I was a girl. So the lengths that I had to go to just to get people to listen. And when I went into the room and I said, the way that we're doing things now, it won't work. And getting someone to actually listen to that, it was so hard. when they bought my idea. They called a meeting with 20 male engineers
然而，我的整个职业生涯基本上就是，我走进的每一个房间，我都必须证明自己有能力待在这个房间里，所以这就像我的整个职业生涯都是从一进门时负500分开始努力的，因此，我所设法在思科内部做出的改变是，我们为会议室制造了这些网真系统，我做了大量的研究，我做了大约20个小时的演讲，我制作了原型，我实际制作了一个完整的产品，带有摄像头、麦克风阵列和触摸屏，上面还有网页相关的东西。我真的不得不这样做，因为没有人听我的，因为我是个女孩。为了让别人听我说话，我付出了巨大的努力。当我走进房间说，我们现在做事的方式行不通时。要让别人真正听进去，实在是太难了。当他们采纳我的想法时，他们召集了一个由20名男性工程师参加的会议
and they didn't ask me to come. I think you're absolutely right. And I think people like Chandler and I, I think we tend to be loud people who, we have strong opinions and we don't have a problem sharing them. And I think because we're, you know, white guys in tech, that's very accepted, right? That, you know, like if I spend most of my time going into meetings and pitching people on crazy
却没有邀请我参加。我觉得你完全说得对。而且我认为像钱德勒和我这样的人，我觉得我们往往是声音比较大的人，我们有强烈的观点，而且我们不介意分享这些观点。我想因为我们是科技行业的白人男性，这非常被接受，对吧？你知道，如果我把大部分时间都花在开会和向人们推销疯狂的
ideas that nobody believes in yet and trying to convince them to believe in that. And it's easier for me to do that because I know that it's acceptable for me to do that and that I feel confident doing that. But you, Patricia, as a woman in tech, one, you're not going to feel as comfortable doing that because you know that there's a huge bias against you and two it's so much harder for people to listen i would be the one presenting and people would shush me in the meeting i had a guy who was like an executive saying in the meeting who do you think you are and i was like i'm i'm just here answering a question you asked me.
还没人相信的想法，并试图说服他们相信这一点。对我来说，这样做更容易，因为我知道这样做是可以被接受的，而且我对此感到自信。但是你，帕特莉夏，作为一个科技行业的女性，第一，你不会觉得那么自在，因为你知道对你有巨大的偏见，第二，人们听取你的意见要困难得多。我本该是那个做演示的人，但在会议上人们却让我嘘声闭嘴。我曾遇到一个像高管一样的人在会议上说，你以为你是谁，而我说，我，我只是来回答你问我的问题。
I think there's also, like, it's weird, right? Because one of the things that I've been fairly lucky with is that, you know, certainly I get a foot in the door right but being by looking like everyone's expected image of of random geek helps um but i think it's important for people to realize that um that that helps and it makes a big difference but i actually think the goal and like the challenge is is it's structurally the same it's a difference it's a it's different than magnitude a big difference in magnitude but you still have to convince people to listen to you well the thing is that the thing is in the end
我觉得这也挺奇怪的，对吧？因为我比较幸运的一点是，当然，我能踏进这扇门，但长得符合大家对随机极客的预期形象确实有帮助，嗯，但我认为让人意识到这一点很重要，嗯，这确实有帮助，而且影响很大，但我实际上认为目标和挑战在结构上是一样的，规模不同，规模上有很大差异，但你仍然得说服别人听你说话，好吧，关键是，关键在于最后
the way the way i won was by proving my point i didn't win by convincing anyone like i i convinced them by by proving the math i i didn't convince them because they believed in me they didn't believe in me at all what i managed to do was to prove by implementing by it because what i was saying was not and no matter how much research and no matter how much i would present nobody would believe me. So the only and this is the reason why I won. And this is also one of the reasons why I think women have to be engineers. Because I won because I could make it. I would have never won if what I came in there was was some kind of like crazy idea. I came in with a product. I could demonstrate it.
我赢的方式是证明我的观点，我不是靠说服任何人赢的，我是靠证明数学原理说服他们的，我不是因为他们相信我才说服他们的，他们根本不相信我。我成功做到的是通过实现来证明，因为我说的不是，不管做多少研究，不管我展示多少，都没人相信我。所以唯一的办法，这也是我赢的原因。这也是我认为女性必须成为工程师的原因之一。因为我是靠把它做出来才赢的。如果我当时带去的是某种疯狂的想法，我绝对不可能赢。我是带着产品去的。我能演示它。
What I'm trying to say is that's how everyone ends up winning. At least in the meetings at Google, I certainly have never been able to just convince people. I've had an easier time with it, don't get me wrong. But you always have to to uh i think come in with the product usually usually for me the tide sort of the tide tends to turn like when it's far too late like like like i like i i typically try to convince people of things you know early on um and they only will get on board once it's become inevitable that that's what we're doing. And it's already sort of already happened. But I do think that, yeah, I think what Chandler, what you're saying is right. It's like, yeah, that like oftentimes you're not going to convince people.
我想说的是，每个人最终都是这样赢的。至少在谷歌的会议上，我当然从来没能仅靠说服别人。我做起来要容易一些，别误会我。但你总是得，呃，我觉得通常得带着产品去。通常对我来说，风向往往是在为时已晚的时候才开始转变的，比如，比如，我通常会试着在早期说服别人，嗯，而他们只有在事情变得不可避免——这正是我们要做的——的时候才会加入。而且那已经算是发生过了。但我确实觉得，对吧，我觉得钱德勒，你说的对。就像，对吧，很多时候你根本说服不了别人。
You just have to go and find a way to show them. I had one particular project recently where I sort of realized there's no way that I'm going to convince people if I don't just go show them on that. Although it turned out to be wrong. I was able to convince them otherwise um but but it's harder for for I still think that the bar is different for for if you walk into a room and people don't expect you to be competent then then they will treat you differently they will speak to differently but even worse they will not listen to what you're saying i i've been in meetings where i will speak and then then the next person will speak and nobody will ever mention that i said anything and then you know four minutes later a guy will say exactly what i had said
你只能去找个方法展示给他们看。我最近有个特别的项目，我当时意识到，如果我不直接展示给他们看，我是绝对没法说服他们的。尽管后来证明我是错的。我能够说服他们接受另一种观点，嗯，但我仍然认为，对于——如果你走进一个房间，人们不期望你有能力，那么他们对待你的方式就会不同，他们对你说话的方式也会不同，但更糟糕的是，他们根本不会听你在说什么。我参加过这样的会议：我先发言，然后接着是另一个人发言，但没有人会提到我说过的话，然后，你知道的，四分钟后，有个家伙会说出和我一模一样的话
four minutes earlier and then everybody will be oh yeah very good point and i'm like yeah yeah no but it's i i yeah i i had I had a manager go to me and said Patricia you need to be more like because I said that I would people were stealing my work and you know and he was like yeah you have to be more assertive and you have to like like like say I made that and blah blah blah and it's like and and so I was like okay fine because you know that's how all of this process works. It turns it against you. So it's you that's wrong. It's not the system that's wrong.
四分钟前说过的话，然后所有人都会说：“哦，对，说得好。”而我就像：“对，对，不，但是……”我有个经理对我说：“帕特里夏，你需要更像……”因为我说过别人在窃取我的工作，你知道的，他就说：“对，你需要更自信，你需要像……说‘这是我做的’之类的话，”然后我就觉得，好吧，行吧，因为你知道，所有的流程都是这样运作的。它把责任推卸到你身上。所以错的是你。错的不是这个系统。
It's you that's wrong. So I was like, okay, fine. So the next time somebody presented my work as their work, I said, yeah, it's great that you could use the thing that I made to do this. And my boss was furious. Yeah, he was yelling at me. And I was like, I'm sorry, but this was what you told me to do. I'm sorry, I can't win here. It's like, there's no, this is not a game that is winnable.
错的是你。所以我想，好吧，行吧。所以下次有人把我的工作当成他们自己的工作展示时，我说：“太棒了，你能用我做东西来做这个。”我老板气疯了。对，他在对我大喊大叫。我说：“对不起，但这就是你告诉我要做的事。对不起，我在这里根本赢不了。这就好像，没有，这不是一场能赢的游戏。”
I mean, I think the only winning move is to, you know, go to a company or an organization where this does not happen. That's the winning move. One thing I have found tends to help here, at least in my experience, is if there's something where I've said it, or I feel like I'm answering the same question multiple times, or I'm explaining something, and people are just not hearing the words, they're just hearing whatever they want in it that is often when i realize okay it is now time for me to write this down in some
我的意思是，我认为唯一的获胜之道就是，你知道的，去一家不会发生这种事的公司或组织。这才是获胜之道。我发现在这方面往往有帮助的一点是，至少根据我的经验，如果我说过某些话，或者我觉得自己在重复回答同一个问题，或者我在解释什么，而人们根本没有听进去，他们只是在其中听到他们想听到的东西，通常那就是我意识到——好吧，现在是我把这些写下来的时候了
document or put it in slides or something um and it sort of sort of to have some sort of paper trail where the next time that it comes up i can just instead, instead of giving the explanation again, I can just point at, I'm not going to get into that right now. Look here. We've already done that. And here's the paper trail. And like, here's the answer to your question. Yeah. I had to do that all the time. There's no way for me to come into it. And that was also when my boss was like, yeah, why do you always bring a PowerPoint presentation to every every meeting and i was like not only do i bring a powerpoint presentation to the meeting i will send it in the invite you nobody can come and tell me that they did not see it or didn't get it and that it's not documented and time stamped i've started in every meeting that I run, I take detailed minutes and I send them out.
文档里，或者做成幻灯片什么的，嗯，留个纸面记录，这样下次再出现这种情况时，我就可以不用再解释一遍，而是直接指向……我现在不想扯那个。看这里。我们已经做过这个了。纸面记录就在这里。比如，这就是你问题的答案。对。我以前总是得这么做。我根本没有别的办法。这也是我老板问：“为什么你每次开会都要带个PowerPoint演示文稿？”的时候，我说：“我不但会带PPT去开会，我还会把它发在会议邀请里，没有人能跑来告诉我他们没看见、没收到，或者说它没有被记录存档、没有时间戳。”我开始在我主持的每个会议上都做详细的会议纪要并发送出去。
And I almost never read the minutes like immediately afterwards. A couple of the people who are on the meeting invites do read them and give feedback. So they are useful in that regard. But the primary reason that I do this is that three or four or five times a year, I get asked for a paper trail on something. And I now have this magical power where I can be like, that happened on this date, on this date, on this date. And we said, you said that, that, and that, and that. And it's just like, end of discussion.
而且我几乎从不在会后马上阅读这些纪要。参会的人中确实有几个人会读并给出反馈。所以从这方面来看它们是有用的。但我这样做的主要原因是，一年下来总有三四五次，会有人要求我提供某事的纸面记录。现在我拥有了一种神奇的力量，我可以淡定地说：“那件事发生在某年某月某日、某年某月某日、某年某月某日。当时我们说过，你当时说过这个、那个、还有这个。”这就好像，讨论结束。
I had a wonderful, like two mentors or bosses, I guess, at some point in my career. And they had a very good, like, motto. They said that the people who write the minutes decide what was said. Yeah. So they said whenever you are in, like, a meeting, especially if it's antagonistic in some way, you make sure you are the ones writing the minutes.
我职业生涯某个阶段曾有过很棒的两位导师或老板，我想是这样的。他们有一个非常好的座右铭。他们说，写会议纪要的人决定了会议上说了什么。对。所以他们说，无论你什么时候开会，尤其是带有某种对抗性质的会议，你一定要确保自己是写会议纪要的那个人。
And this is, if you look at the history of the COBOL programming language, which was the first language developed by a committee, that's one of the, and it's, COBOL's a very interesting language because it was developed in the 60s and most of the primary people behind its development were women. Well, how did that come to be? Well, two reasons. One, at that time, being an engineer or a programmer was not, you know, the cool thing. It was all about being a businessman, the business logic. So most of
如果你看看COBOL编程语言的历史——这是由委员会开发的第一个语言——这就是其中之一，而且，COBOL是一门非常有趣的语言，因为它是在20世纪60年代开发的，其背后的主要开发人员大多是女性。这怎么可能呢？嗯，原因有二。第一，在当时，成为一名工程师或程序员并不是什么酷的事。当时最吃香的是成为一个商人、搞商业逻辑。所以大多数
the technical people involved were women. But two, who took the minutes in those meetings? Who was the one that was running the meetings where they were developing COBOL. It was always the women, the heads of all of the subgroups of the COBOL committee. I think 60 or 70% of them were women. And there is an incredible power in being the person that is running the meeting or that takes the minutes. You get to literally write history. So I i'm just curious should we try and get back to mr cruz we'll pause here and resume part three next week thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
参与的技术人员都是女性。但第二，谁在会议上做记录？谁是开发COBOL时主持会议的人？总是女性，也就是COBOL委员会各个小组的负责人。我想其中60%或70%都是女性。作为主持会议或做会议纪要的人，这其中蕴含着巨大的力量。你实际上可以书写历史。所以，我只是好奇，我们是不是该试着回到克鲁兹先生的话题？我们今天就到这里，下周继续第三部分，感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。